injecting testosterone if you don't need  it seems like a bad idea what happens if  you're a man with regular levels of  testosterone and you give yourself a  little boost from like an actual  testicular Health aspect you're  essentially shutting down the signal to  them in order to minorly elevate your  levels just for some hopeful Improvement  in cognitive sharpness muscle building  potential Etc some people do need it for  sure and there's like absolute utility  in it and it's very very effective when  it's needed and warranted but a lot of  people I think haphazardly get on it and  may not otherwise need it and then they  end up reliant on it for their entire  lives